hi this is preshtalwalker in this video
we're going to explain why gas stations
are often located next to each other
let's think about two hot dog stands
that are on a beach
each hot dog sand wants to be closest to
the most customers
we can think about the shoreline as
being a straight line that goes from one
end to the other
if the blue and green hot dog stands
spread out evenly across the beach
then the blue stand will get all the
customers to the left of the middle
and the green stand will get all the
customers to the right of the middle
this location of the two stands is very
good for everyone involved
the two stands spread the beach evenly
and they're closest
to customers on both sides
customers left of center can go to the
blue stand and customers right at the
center can go to the green stand
however
each stand wants to locate to be closer
to more customers
so the green stand thinks
what happens if i move closer to the
blue stand
when the green stand moves closer
it actually captures some of the
customers that were going to the blue
stand
so now the green stand has more than
half of the beach because it's closer to
more customers
the blue stand thinks about the
situation and decides that it can get
its customers back by moving closer to
the center as well
so the blue stand moves over to the
center
and it regains some of its customers
as you can see the blue and green stands
both want to move closer to the center
so that they can get more customers and
be closer
to customers than the other stand
ultimately they both end up at the
center
and at this point they're equally close
to all the customers that are along the
shoreline
so they split the customers evenly
and there's an interesting thing at this
point is that neither stand is going to
want to move
if either stand moves to the left or the
right
then that stand is going to get less
than half the customers
so this is the solution to the game
and this is the reason why businesses
often locate right next to each other
when competing on location
everyone wants the central location to
be as close to as many customers as
possible
this is true for gas stations it's also
true for fast food chains
and it's even true for political
candidates
during election campaigns
they all go to the center position to
seek out the average vote
so although we would be better served if
the stands and businesses were spread
out
because of competition they all moved to
the center
i hope you like this video please
subscribe to my channel
you can catch me on my blog mind your
decisions or on twitter at
preshtalwalker
and if you like this video please buy my
book on game theory
this example of gas stations is the
first chapter in my book you can get my
book in paperback and ebook form at
amazon.com
it's called the joy of game theory an
introduction to strategic thinking